[Música]
'ecuador cumple ya 10 días de
manifestaciones bloqueos y disturbios en
sus calles debido a una serie de
protestas lideradas por la conaie que es
la confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas del ecuador que piden estos
grupos indígenas son 10 peticiones en
total pero puedo destacar les algunas de
ellas como por ejemplo la congelación de
los precios de los combustibles que han
aumentado debido al incremento en los
precios internacionales del petróleo
esta es una realidad que afecta no
solamente ecuador sino a muchos países
en el mundo también piden que los bancos
privados y públicos perdonen y extiendan
el plazo de pagos de deuda a 4 millones
de ecuatorianos también exigen inversión
pública mejoras en las condiciones
laborales y corregir el
desabastecimiento que hay de
medicamentos e implementos en diferentes
hospitales públicos de ecuador- esto
solamente por mencionar algunos puntos
veamos que más dicen desde el lado de
los grupos indígenas escuchemos el
movimiento indígena del ecuador
agrupados en la conaie y las otras
organizaciones sociales
movilizadas estamos dispuestos a dar una
respuesta que permita abrir la discusión
sobre los mecanismos de cumplimiento de
los puntos por los que nos hemos tomado
esta movilización a nivel nacional estas
condiciones supone una serie de voluntad
del gobierno nacional para bajar las
acciones represivas de rogar el estado
de excepción y la desmilitarización del
parque el arbolito el gobierno respondió
con un despliegue de operaciones
coordinadas entre la policía y las
fuerzas armadas para dispersar estas
manifestaciones en las calles y en las
principales carreteras del país que ya
están impidiendo el abastecimiento de
algunas poblaciones el gobierno también
instauró el estado de excepción para dos
provincias para cotopaxi y para
pichincha pero tres días después lo
derogó y lo impuso nuevamente y lo
extendió a otras provincias como
imbabura chimborazo pastaza y tungurahua
desde el ministerio de defensa el
ministro luís lara que es el encargado
de esta cartera ha indicado que ante la
inestabilidad y la crisis que se está
viviendo en ecuador la democracia del
país está en peligro
ecuatorianos
la democracia del ecuador está en serio
riesgo
ante la acción concertada de personas
exaltadas que impiden la libre
circulación de la mayoría de los
ecuatorianos las fuerzas armadas no
permitirán que se intente romper el
orden constitucional
o cualquier acción contra la democracia
y de las leyes de la república
por su parte el presidente guillermo
lasso ofreció dialogar pero la conaie
dijo que lo haría hasta que fuera
levantado el estado de excepción y que
el gobierno retirara las fuerzas de
seguridad de las diferentes zonas donde
ellos están concentrados manifestándose
ante una iniciativa de diálogo que vino
desde diferentes sectores de la sociedad
civil el presidente lazo dijo a través
de su cuenta de twitter que estaba
dispuesto a dialogar
el gobierno nacional ha acogido gran
parte de las sugerencias presentadas en
la agenda de la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas de ecuador
conaie con medidas compensatorias
anunciadas públicamente pero estamos
conscientes de que el proceso de
solución de los problemas de un país es
dinámico y por lo tanto estamos
dispuestos a identificar en conjunto las
mejores formas y vías para estas
soluciones
la última vez que la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas se manifestó en
las calles fue en octubre de 2019 y
llevó a la paralización del país por 20
días y sólo hubo un entendimiento entre
las partes tras una mediación por parte
de naciones unidas- y también de la
iglesia católica en ese entonces el
presidente de lenin moreno dio marcha
atrás a su idea de eliminar la ayuda
estatal a los combustibles para el
consumidor en esta oportunidad la
invitación a negociar viene desde la
sociedad civil también desde la
organización de naciones unidas y desde
la unión europea la situación y la
atención en ecuador se incrementa con el
paso de los horas por eso es nuestro
tema de análisis y debate hoy en nuestro
programa y para conversar sobre este
temas saludamos a maría paz services
ella es decana de la facultad de
ciencias sociales y jurídicas de la wii
sé que ella se encuentra en la ciudad de
quito y desde la ciudad de guayaquil en
la costa del pacífico ecuatoriano está
gabriela panchana briones ella es
analista y comunicadora social les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar todas
las preguntas y comentarios que deseen a
través de las redes sociales
estamos en twitter en instagram y en
facebook en donde nos encuentran como
france24
s santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
en youtube pueden seguir nuestra señal
de streaming en vivo también los invito
para que escuchen nuestro podcast de el
debate de france 24 estamos en app el
podcast también estamos en spotify en
dice 21 en la etiqueta para que usted
deje todos los comentarios ya se la
recuerdo es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos su participación en este
programa a través de sus comentarios en
las redes sociales comienzo entonces con
mi invitada en la ciudad de quito le doy
la bienvenida entonces a maria paz
gracias por acompañarnos hoy en el
programa y punto de partida que es como
llamo yo a la pregunta inicial para
conocer posiciones sobre este tema cuál
es su perspectiva su panorama general de
la situación en ecuador una protesta de
descontento por parte de los indígenas
es una crisis de gobernabilidad por
parte del gobierno del presidente lazo
cuál es su opinión
buenas noches santiago es un gusto
nuevamente estar contigo en este espacio
y quienes nos escuchan pero son momentos
muy dramáticos para el ecuador con tú
mencionabas qué tipo donde le identificó
yo este fenómeno tiene un poquito de
todo pero me inclino a pensar que esto
se trata de un intento más de golpe de
estado de un intento de anarquía del
golpismo de sectores donde liderazgos
indígenas que están muy asociados al
crimen organizado hagan la narcopolítica
que se está instaurado en el ecuador sin
perjuicio de que existen descontentos
sociales que son reales que son
legítimos que lamentablemente son
estructurales en el estado ecuatoriano
es decir que que tenemos que reconocer
que una de las grandes tragedias de
nuestro estado es que tenemos un
porcentaje de la población absolutamente
abandonada en la zona del campesinado
donde mayoritariamente la población es
indígena donde tenemos provincias de la
sierra centro del país donde tenemos 40
por ciento de desnutrición infantil y
que estos problemas como digo son
estructurales desde hace desde el diseño
del estado que ningún gobierno se ha
comprometido con el cambio también que
reconocer que este gobierno en
particular ha tenido una debilidad en
gestión política y que también
definitivamente se evidencia en estos
días pero de lo que estamos viviendo en
el ecuador es un caos una crisis que nos
puede conducir a una a unas condiciones
de guerra interna dramáticas donde
quienes llevan la batuta son los más
violentos y donde vemos financiamiento
externo externo al estado ya la sociedad
civil es decir probablemente del crimen
organizado pasó a presentar a gabriela
en la ciudad de guayaquil gracias por
acompañarnos gabriela también punto de
partida a la misma pregunta su panorama
general perspectiva sobre este tema ya
conocíamos y vimos hace unos segundos el
de marjah paz cuál es su punto de vista
hola santiago hola maría paz también
saludos a la audiencia me parece que hay
una digamos una conflagración de
diferentes temas comparto que hay
necesidades reales y legítimas que de
alguna manera están vistiendo de
protesta social probablemente utilizando
a gente pobre que tiene la que ha sido
manipulada por por diligencias que sí
tienen una agenda política y que de
alguna manera está aprovechando la
crisis que no solamente es crisis del
ecuador sino una crisis global
y un probable un lamentable manejo poco
digamos poco adecuado del gobierno en
términos de estrategia política y de
comunicación todo esto ha sido está
siendo aprovechado y está siendo
aprovechado por fuerzas que tienen una
clara agenda de impunidad y que están
relacionadas con el narcotráfico con la
narcoviolencia
días antes de que estallara este paro
se dio un fuerte golpe a quienes a un
narcotraficante que financiaba las
diferentes bandas que hacían digamos
masacres tanto carcelarias como
sicariatos fuera de la cárcel este este
señor
aleandro norero fue encontrado en su
casa una casa de más de dos millones de
dólares que donde tenía dinero en
efectivo lujoso de oro que se calcula
más de 10 millones de dólares en eso y
que cuya cuya casa estaba a nombre de un
señor que se llama javier jordán que
está relacionado con la corrupción de
hospitales y que luego apareció en una
piscina con una asambleísta del
correísmo digamos nada de estas cosas
pueden ser quitadas del análisis porque
de alguna manera hay una hay una hay una
operación una colaboración
que tiene que también ser parte del
análisis claro gabriela no puedo dejarlo
de lado precisamente esa era mi
siguiente pregunta para usted' hago la
ronda a la inversa ya le doy la palabra
a maría paz sobre estas manifestaciones
una unos reclamos verdaderos legítimos
por parte de algunos sectores de la
sociedad ecuatoriana pero cuál es
entonces son esos intereses que puede
haber ya usted mencionaba algunos de
ellos profundizamos en el tema porque
esto se empieza a parecer a un escenario
similar al que vivió colombia el año
pasado y también a lo que vivió chile ya
hace algunos meses atrás donde hubo unas
manifestaciones sociales con unos
reclamos contundentes pero que siempre
se dijo que estas manifestaciones
masivas habían tenido algunas manos
infiltradas de diferentes sectores que
piden simplemente
desestabilizar al gobierno de turno
sí yo creo que es cuestión de unir los
puntos
este gobierno a partir del 24 de mayo
del 2021 se triplicaron los actos de
violencia que ahora sabemos tienen un
vínculo directo con el narcotráfico y
con
lamentablemente debo decirlo con la
narcopolítica y sin que hubiera ninguna
otra razón digamos el a partir del 24 de
mayo del 2021 no hay una escalada de
sicariatos y de
masacres en las cárceles donde las
cárceles sabemos están siendo han sido
controladas desde hace muchos años por
capos de bandas vinculadas al
microtráfico y el tráfico de drogas
por otro lado ha habido una escalada
también de incautaciones de cocaína en
el breve espacio que ha gobernado este
guillermo lasso se han se han incautado
cuatrocientas toneladas de cocaína
muchísimo más que durante los años
anteriores y eso tiene un costo que en
el mercado de miles de millones de
dólares entonces
tenemos esto tenemos este escenario
tenemos y tenemos legítimas protestas
entonces ya en el 2019 se encontraron
vínculos entre los entre infiltrados que
es que inclusive quemaron un edificio de
la contraloría trataron de quemar un
canal de televisión es decir eso no se
lo puede aislar y la misma blemente
desde la conaie lo único que dice es son
infiltrados entonces son infiltrados
pero alguien tiene que hacerse cargo
ellos no quieren que esté la fuerza
policial ni los militares quien protege
a la mayor de la sociedad pacífica que
lo único que quiere es que la dejen
trabajar y
seguir adelante claro uno uno puede
entender de acuerdo a la historia
ecuatoriana maría paz que los grupos
indígenas tienen cierto peso
a nivel social a nivel de la protesta
para salir a exigir sus derechos o hacer
sus reclamos legítimos ante el gobierno
lo hemos visto a lo largo de los años ya
lo citaba yo los hechos durante el
gobierno del presidente el lenin moreno
en su momento también enfrentó una
crisis social y manifestaciones en la
calle pero maría paz el tema de la
violencia dejando un momentico de lado
el tema de las manifestaciones indígenas
el tema de la violencia como lo decía
gabriela se ha venido incrementando en
los últimos meses esto era una verdad
oculta que había en ecuador este grado
de violencia en las cárceles está este
grado de d
infiltraciones por parte del
narcotráfico a nivel político a nivel de
la sociedad ecuatoriana y que ahora
viene a darse a conocer oa explotar así
en los medios de comunicación o es un
fenómeno que venía desde antes
a ver vamos a ver cómo gabriel
efectivamente nos ha puesto en evidencia
este atar cabos lo cierto y el ver cómo
se correlaciona de estos fenómenos de la
de la violencia y de la política
yo quisiera aquí aunque es muy
lamentable y quisiéramos los
ecuatorianos poder mirar hacia adelante
dejando de lado el gobierno el fatídico
y extenso gobierno de rafael correa pero
no podemos hacerlo porque hay que
entender que es ahí donde se originan
muchas cosas de lo que estamos viviendo
ahorita no todo evidentemente pero
muchas cosas y el fenómeno de la
violencia las cárceles en el ecuador
como ha pasado en américa latina' nunca
han sido espacios de verdadera
rehabilitación efectivamente sin embargo
nosotros tenemos que identificar una
reforma penal que ocurre precisamente va
durante el gobierno de rafael correa y
lo que propone esta es una visión
extremadamente punitiva que queremos
decir con esto esa visión en el del
derecho penal del castigo constante no
de la prevención entonces se incrementa
en gran medida en el castigo y las penas
de privación de libertad es decir se
mete más presos a las cárceles y tenemos
un incremento de la población carcelaria
mons el hacinamiento que ya era un
problema en el ecuador se incrementa
profundamente por un lado por otro lado
lo que nosotros tenemos que observar es
que durante el gobierno de correa hubo
mucha habilidad para contar a los grupos
criminales a que sean parte del gobierno
ya qué me refiero el fenómeno de las
pandillas el fenómeno de las naciones
que es algo que pasó en toda américa
desde canadá hasta el sur y sin embargo
en esa necesidad de tener estas fuerzas
de choque de tener unas militancias de
2000 3000 personas convocados a cada
meeting lo que se hizo durante el
gobierno de correa fue promover estos
espacios de legalización e incorporar a
estos grupos
que son grupos ciertamente delictivos de
la sociedad civil y se les incorporó y
no sólo eso ahí tenía esta militancia es
súper leal y súper presente pero además
tenemos gente que entró a hacer negocio
en el estado la gente que ganaba los
contratos para estas campañas de esta
difusión estos eventos artísticos entre
comillas esto nosotros vimos y creo que
es un poco dejamos por fuera del
análisis pero es uno de los tantos
elementos
el correísmo gobernar con fuerzas de
choque recordemos que el correísmo se
acabó ventajosamente en lo formal pero
que es tenemos un montón de gente es
ciertamente siempre había sido excluida
de la sociedad legal y formal
que perdió el capital político pero
sobre todo que perdieron el negocio sin
hablar de todo lo que se generó en
términos geopolíticos para favorecer el
estado ecuatoriano para el lugar donde
operan los cárteles de la droga entonces
todos estos elementos en otras palabras
que es lo que decimos aquí comúnmente
que pasa en los centros de reclusión que
durante el gobierno del corréis no había
un pacto se entregó a las distintas
bandas criminales el control de las
distintas cárceles del país cuando se
acabó este gobierno nuevamente el estado
tuvo que controlar cárceles
superpobladas con mayor hacinamiento y
se les retiró este control no formal y
entonces pudimos observar esta escalada
de violencia y finalmente quisiera
insistir en el tema de que en el caos en
la anarquía es donde los violentos ganan
lo cierto entonces obviamente es muy
rentable el y lo que está promoviendo es
de esta grave condición de conmoción
interna como pasó en octubre de 2019 y
no se salieron con la suya del todo y
ahora esto que vemos porque si me
permite para concluir aquí el tema de
negociar negociar es el camino de
cualquier diálogo lo cierto y nosotros
vemos que el gobierno nacional con la
torpeza política que le ha caracterizado
ha cedido hubo un pliego de peticiones
por parte del movimiento indígena y
muchísimas de estas peticiones muchas
irreales aceptó el gobierno nacional
generando un gasto de más o menos 500
mil millones de dólares y sin embargo
leonidas iza y los representantes de la
conaie siguen diciendo que ellos no se
sientan a negociar y siguen
incrementando el pliego de peticiones
entonces aquí yo hago un llamado a la
sensibilización porque vemos muchas
voces que dicen que serán las dos partes
cual que serán las dos partes tenemos un
gobierno nacional que aceptó una serie
de exigencias irreales que acepta la
invitación para ir al diálogo y tenemos
un grupo de dirigentes de un pedacito
pequeño de la población incrementan las
exigencias y que no quieren dialogar lo
que ellos quieren es tumbar al gobierno
esa era mi pregunta maría paz
quieren tumbar al presidente lazo
sacarlo del poder
quieren simplemente dar esta imagen de
conmoción interna de desorden de caos
que el gobierno no es capaz de controlar
lo que sucede al interior del país o
simplemente lo quieren dejar en el punto
como al borde del abismo que está
tambaleando y no generar un problema
político como tendrá que llamar a unas
nuevas elecciones o ver caer a un
presidente que se exilio o algo así que
ya es un diccionario que hemos visto en
ecuador' varias veces a quien le resulta
incómodo el presidente lazo
me adelanté un poco porque creo que todo
esto va atado no en el hilo conductor de
estos fenómenos de violencia lo que
nosotros vemos es que cualquier régimen
democrático inclusive uno no competente
políticamente como ha sido hasta ahora
el gobierno del presidente lazo es
absolutamente incómodo para las bandas
criminales es decir si no está el
correísmo que es donde ellos han pactado
libremente esto ya no le resulta un buen
negocio entonces creo que ellos buscan
el caos que es lo que ellos buscan
romper el orden constituido porque
muchas voces que hacemos opinión pública
desde nuestros distintos espacios lo mío
la academia en la relación entre lo
público y privado porque insistimos en
defender no al presidente del gobierno
lanzó a quien le cuestionamos y le
demandamos que hacemos escrutinio todos
los días de nuestra vida sino que
defendemos el orden constitucional sí
porque este es un buen negocio la hoja
de ruta es un poco lo que ya vimos en
octubre de 2019 nos como no puedo pensar
desde una mente criminal no sé
exactamente cuáles son los pasos que
ellos quieren seguir pero lo que yo sí
puedo ver como una negociadora formada
que es parte de mi formación es que para
negociar
a ver voluntad de las partes y una
voluntad es por ejemplo iniciar desde
una sesión de postura como aceptaron a
la pasión a negociar como aceptar por
ejemplo el gobierno nacional varias de
estas peticiones irreales o un gasto
insisto de alrededor 500 millones de
dólares estas cifras se tiene que
escuchar y tenemos al otro lado una
contraparte que dice no no no yo sigo
pidiendo más cosas entonces
definitivamente lo que buscan es el caos
es la violencia y estoy segura que es
volver a gobernar y eso se dedican
filtrado audios que se escuchen esos
mítines diciendo cuánto les va a costar
votar al presidente las
gabriela en la ciudad de guayaquil allí
en la perla del pacífico ecuatoriano su
opinión
también me parece que está claro que a
quién le conviene es a quienes buscan la
impunidad para seguir haciendo lo que
estaban haciendo de manera cómoda y
cómplice con el gobierno el gobierno de
correa porque cabe indicar que durante
el gobierno de moreno que llegó al poder
auspiciado por el pobre del correísmo y
que dio este giro cuando por las razones
que haya sido que encontró dice él lo
que el control que la mesa no estaba
servida o todos los los casos de
corrupción que por alguna razón a él no
había conocido antes como él llegó con
las fuerzas del correísmo él tenía parte
de la asamblea
digamos más o menos de su lado se
dividió el bloque que tenía el correísmo
en la asamblea durante el gobierno de
moreno el presidente que estaba en el
año 2010 y no del presidente de la
asamblea no sé sí o no mientras duró el
caos claro el caos también era mucho
mayor ahora en contraste de esto vemos
que la asamblea en la asamblea te tienes
a 49 asambleístas del correísmo y
tantos asambleístas de pachakutik en el
brazo político de la conaie entonces ese
escenario hace que sea mucho mucho más
fácil mucho más factible que haya una un
golpe de estado hasta cierto punto
constitucional es decir por salvar al
gobierno al llegar a una muerte cruzada
esto es a disolver la asamblea y a
llamar a elecciones
generales donde el presidente también
pone a disposición su cargo y
salirse de alguna manera con la de ellos
no sé esto en un momento en el que
estamos a pocos meses de las elecciones
excepcionales que son en febrero y que
por el desgaste político normal del
gobierno y también por el pobre manejo
que ha tenido de la gestión política
podría significar que los grandes
ganadores digamos que va a acudir a esta
salida constitucional
promovida por las calles promovidas por
la violencia que estamos viendo en las
calles podría significar que en febrero
de 2023 el correísmo no sólo recupere el
poder digamos de la del ejecutivo sino
también del legislativo y además de las
seccionales es decir de las alcaldías de
las prefecturas ese es el escenario y
eso es lo que creo debemos de ver la
mayoría de ecuatorianos que lo único que
queremos hacer es vivir en un estado que
no sea un narcoestado
gabriela que tan permea hasta la
política con la ecuatoriana perdón de
grupos de narcotráfico y de estas bandas
delincuenciales y desde cuando ecuador
pasó a ser un hub de distribución de
carteles internacionales a través de la
costa del pacífico
de droga que viene tanto de de perú como
de colombia para salir por el pacífico
para llegar a méxico para llegar a
estados unidos no sé si tenga algo que
ver el momento en que la base militar de
eeuu en la ciudad de manta fue
eliminada precisamente por la
administración de correa
bueno en el negocio del narcotráfico es
un negocio como sabemos que mueve
muchísimos miles de millones de dólares
que es lo que busca alguien que hace de
negocios busca bajar los costos para la
distribución y para la producto para
toda la cadena digamos de un negocio
desde el gobierno del señor rafael
correa en el 2007 se dieron una serie de
pasos que disminuyeron el costo de
traficar o de pasar la droga y de
distribuirla a través de las costas
ecuatorianas hacia los mercados de
europa y de eeuu entonces esto se dio a
través de eliminarla el convenio que
tenía con eeuu en la base de demanda a
través de la contratación de estos
radares que no servían para nada y a
través de una serie de políticas que
generaron digamos esta complicidad
con la con las farc y con los
narcotraficantes esto es tan evidente
que en el juicio de el chapo guzmán en
eeuu hubo declaraciones que mostraban
como él chapeau decía que él tenía él
manejaba gente en la policía en las
fuerzas armadas de hecho en el año en el
año durante el gobierno de moreno se
encontró una tonelada de cocaína en una
de las bases militares entonces
obviamente lograron infiltrar a parte
del estado de la exclusiva de las
fuerzas armadas de los eeuu en el
ecuador han dicho que ha habido narcos
generales que le han quitado la visa por
eso digamos estamos completamente
contaminados la diferencia es que antes
esta contaminación era voluntaria
digamos el estado el gobierno estaba
completa estaba de acuerdo con esto y
ahora hay un gobierno que está luchando
contra esto que es un monstruo y que por
eso ha pedido ayuda de eeuu de israel y
de colombia pero que no es un problema
que se va a resolver ni con golpes de
estado ni con cambios abruptos
de muerte cruzada o de institución del
presidente
pero que lo que busca es eso buscar
volver al cómo estaban cómodos muy bien
atendidos con en el gobierno del
correísmo maría paz no está usted tal
vez una similitud en el libreto de lo
que yo mencionaba hace unos minutos
estas manifestaciones este descontento
social que se suma a estas posibles
infiltraciones ya éstas
manos externas relacionadas con el
narcotráfico
que están sucediendo y que están
teniendo lugar allí en ecuador con el
escenario que vivió colombia hace ya un
año y lo que vivió en chile y vemos que
en ambos países pues los gobiernos que
han llegado han sido gobiernos de
izquierda es para propiciar estos
cambios esta alternancia en el poder
está llegada de esto de estos gobiernos
de tendencia de izquierda
sí ciertamente creo que el socialismo
del siglo 21 ha instaurado una nueva
clase delictiva en transnacionales y
ciertamente es así hay un patrón común
tienen par de ellos y quiero hablar
desde un punto de vista quizás del dolor
de la ciudadanía ecuatoriana porque
nosotros en el ecuador
hemos sentido profundo orgullo del
mecanismo de construcción de derechos de
ciudadanía de un estado pluricultural y
multiétnico en un movimiento indígena
absolutamente valiente que ha luchado
por sus derechos yo crecí en la década
de los noventas y me imagino que el caso
de gabriel es igual con profunda
admiración a ver como muchas veces la
protesta social logró reconfigurar la
perspectiva y la concepción de un estado
que tradicionalmente había ignorado la
existencia de la pluriculturalidad
eso no significa que con esos
reconocimientos desde lo formal a partir
de la constitución del 98 por ejemplo
haya desaparecido la
discriminación estructural para nada
sabemos que los pasos que se dan a nivel
jurídico y político son relevantes
porque nos permite identificarnos como
estados con un nivel de mestizaje
importante porque una presencia indígena
muy respetada muy acogida pero todavía
la atención en términos de políticas
públicas para el desarrollo
agrario sobre todo de las zonas rurales
ha sido muy deficiente como ya lo hemos
mencionado el estado ecuatoriano ha sido
un estado muy difícil muy ineficiente
perdón
pero lo que nosotros vemos es que los
últimos años esos liderazgos eran tan
respetados y que nos llenaban de orgullo
en la sociedad ecuatoriana sólo optaba
por la política más perversa más
criminal y lo que tenemos hoy día son
ciudades sitiadas somos ciudadanos
aterrorizados
es violencia es 18 policías
desaparecidos es gente muerta es daños
materiales pérdidas económicas y una
ruptura que nos dejó el correísmo y que
nos como vamos a regresar y le soy
sincera que una fragmentación de la
sociedad y un miedo al otro y una
discriminación constante entre distintos
grupos étnicos de un mismo país es claro
gabriela que tan en riesgo está la
democracia el estado de derecho el orden
constitucional en su país
bueno creo que eso depende de nosotros
depende de que la sociedad pacífica que
es la mayoría del ecuador se plante y
diga no vamos a permitir esto me parece
que eso es lo único que podemos hacer
desde la opinión pública desde las
calles desde las redes sociales en paz
con tranquilidad con empatía sabiendo
que hay legítima hay legítimas
necesidades que nuestros hermanos
indígenas antes han sido desatendidos
han sido manipulados
y que eso hay que resolverlo y que creo
que ahí también el gobierno debería de
generar una especie de plan marshall
para la que las comunidades y los
pueblos indígenas son de manera que se
resuelva los problemas estructurales que
nos han resuelto hasta ahora o se
empiecen a resolver por lo menos claro
me quedan ya pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa maría paz gabriela
les pido sean puntuales en las
respuestas quiero preguntarles entonces
cuál puede ser el mecanismo para salir
por lo menos a esta crisis a esta
coyuntura de este momento estos diez
días que cumple ya ecuador bajo
manifestaciones y con las personas
encerradas en sus casas teniendo que
teletrabajar otra vez como si estuvieran
en la pandemia porque no pueden salir a
las calles porque tampoco está permitido
transitar y dónde está el estado de
excepción instaurado en seis provincias
del país es el diálogo es la mano dura
por parte del gobierno una mayor margen
de maniobra por parte del presidente
lazo que opciones puede haber por lo
menos para solucionar esta coyuntura
porque ya vemos que el problema pues es
estructural
el diálogo de verdad debe darse para eso
las partes tienen que negociar el estado
a través del gobierno nacional está
dispuesto a negociar ahora nos hace
falta que la dirigencia indígena le
ponga sus posturas y sus exigencias y se
siente a negociar si eso no pasa
nosotros tenemos que ver que el estado
ecuatoriano como cualquier estado
democrático del mundo nos defienda a
nosotros a los ciudadanos ya las
ciudadanas que si creemos en el diálogo
y que si queremos paz para nuestro país
y gabriela su opinión
creo que la única salida es que dentro
de la dirigencia indígena o dentro de
las comunidades indígenas surjan otros
líderes que puedan influir que puedan
alzar la voz y pedirles que haremos esta
violencia y que las salidas del diálogo
pero creo que debe haber debe de haber
una
una maniobra de alguna manera en pro de
la de la paz dentro de las comunidades
indígenas y también debe de haber un
abrir los oídos y abrir los ojos de
parte del gobierno para sentarse a
promover soluciones mucho más radicales
y contemplen las realidades
del movimiento indígena me queda un
minuto gabriela maria paz en ese orden
de ideas dependiendo de lo que ustedes
acaban de responder cuál entonces pueden
ser ese primer paso gabriela comienzo
con usted
lo que el primer paso es eso es
encontrar otros factores dentro de la
comunidad de las comunidades indígenas
que puedan ser oídos y que no tengan
este está suma cero como discurso sme
todo o nada es esa creo que es la
primera la primera cosa que debe ocurrir
involucrar actores internacionales a la
iglesia también
puede ser puede ser pero el deber si se
consideran legítimos porque yo ni así
sabes legítima nada más de 300
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
donde estaban universidades de iglesia
vaya para su opinión primer paso en la
línea de lo que dice gabriela coincido
con ella voy a mencionar nombres por
ejemplo hay una lideresa indígena
cecilia vásquez que ya ha mostrado en
muchas ocasiones que ya discrepa de
estas formas violentas que si lo hace
leonidas iza porque no miramos a ver qué
pasa con las mujeres detrás del
movimiento indígena porque no
descalificamos a los violentos y buscan
otros actores me sumo a esa propuesta
pues a mariah pasa gabriela en la ciudad
de quito y en guayaquil les agradezco
por haber hecho este análisis sobre la
situación política que se está viviendo
en ecuador a lo largo de estos últimos
días hemos estado muy atentos aquí en
france24 siguiendo minuto a minuto lo
que va sucediendo allí en las calles de
quito y de las diferentes
localidades poblaciones y ciudades en
ecuador vamos a seguir atentos al
desarrollo de esta de esta crisis que se
está viviendo allí les agradezco a las
dos y ustedes pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales pueden seguir dejando también
sus preguntas y no olviden
también en nuestro podcast en las
diferentes plataformas que hay
disponibles sigan con nosotros sigan con
france24
[Música]